okay we recently did an interview with
Cathy O'Neil big data scientist and she
talked about some of the ways in which
big data can harm people the eggman
called in who as you know served time in
a federal penitentiary I believe for
drug-related charges he came up with
ways in which as a white guy he
benefited from big data he called into
our voicemail number two one nine two
david p yesterday and left us the
following little message he gave I
really like the math lady weapons of
mass destruction when I got out of
federal prison they signed you a number
your rate of potential recidivism right
like so one through ten number and they
use some kind of algorithm to figure out
if you're going to be a repeat offender
life
are you married you have a job are you
white you own a house do you have
parents do you go to count all these
friggin things that basically is are you
white my rate of recidivism number was a
zero that means there's no likely in if
I'm going to go back to prison okay and
so far it's been almost twenty years
it's been correct
so the weapons of mass destruction help
you if you have white privilege me being
a white guy did great my parole officer
never even called me I got off parole a
year early so it was I didn't like that
also
hey weapons of mass destruction good for
white privilege yo all right interesting
perspective from the eggman there we
will be talking on the bonus show today
about a ninety eight year-old Minnesota
man who has been outed as a former Nazi
commander we will tell you about what's
going on there a five million dollar
reward has been offered for the full
donald trump tax returns not the first
two pages of his 2005 1040 which only
actually helped him and we will also
give you an update on our DNA tests i
have news
i have an ask pat but i hope he has some
some news to give us about the status of
his DNA test all of those stories and
more on the bonus show get instant
access to the bonus show by signing up
at david pakman.com slash membership we
have a coupon code available for you
that code all lowercase all one word
I voted 17 okay sign up get instant
access to the bonus show
I'll talk to you then